he is a man with wit and with a lot of
golf knowledge from NBC Sports and Golf
Channel our friend David Feherty how are
you David
I'm very well Richie nice to talk to you
again have you ever heard a story like
this David yeah you know I actually know
someone who did that it's not right
who's that no I don't what are you
I mean how many homes allow many
hole-in-ones have you ever had yourself
David I I had eleven and my career but
I'm a lot of them are just lost in the
swirling mists of time I don't remember
where most of them were mhm yeah and I
never won anything for them you know get
a car whatever although I did I did make
one in the Italian Open and Monza I'm
gonna in the 80s yes that where the
Ferrari test track is and they gave me a
Ferrari steering wheel I just thought
was it you know cruel so out of out of
all of what you just heard what's the
most unbelievable part the fact that it
it was Mike Dell too far sound audio
executive as he likes to be referred to
here the first shot he's ever taken on a
golf course that's a B it was a part to
see there's nobody there's nobody who
could actually confirm this happened
David yeah was there a wind melon vault
I give you the floor why I can think it
would happen
you know mice take a miniature golf yeah
let's do anyway that's gonna happen if
there's a client's mouth or a windmill
or something like that
yeah but so you've never heard a story
like this before David right no I I
haven't I've heard a lot of them mm-hmm
you know we just wanted to bring this to
your attention I don't know if you'd
want mike is available for the next
edition to ferdi if you
want to sit down and get a little bit
more in-depth than this David yeah I'd
like to delve into that to be honest
with you okay you know just to see you
know what kind of a psychopath would
actually come up with that what do you
have to say for yourself Mike seriously
like what what what Club was it
what Club was there's a place in New
Jersey no what did you have I know I hit
a hold on the first shot on a 27 hole it
could have been a par 2 as I said as a
joke par 3 course but it was short okay
well David we just wanted to get you on
the show just so you could hear this
take it in and if you do you have any
any are there any you put yourself in my
position
you are a an interviewer as well are
there any follow-up questions we should
ask you in your estimation David well no
no I would I would stop why we're behind
if you know what I mean right I am I am
just happy rich busy in a sport where
you know with the Open Championships
just just finished no that's would be a
big fat guy with bad habits and still
you know when majors I can't think of
any other sport where you gonna do that
maybe darts that's true that's true
or if you're an offensive lineman I
guess in the National Football League
but that's a team sport you're talking
about it you know I'm dividual and that
was great which yeah that was great with
Shane Lowry David that that was it
wasn't it cool yeah that was
unbelievable what was that like to be
there well and I find it very very
difficult to be an impartial observer
which of course is a broadcaster you're
supposed to be it was it wasn't was
amazing you know the province was so
grateful I think you know to have the
tournament back there after so long and
after what you know they've been through
there
the atmosphere was amazed
the crowd was just incredible and to
have an Irishman when it was just you
know a fairy tale
it sure was is there anything you could
tell our listenership viewership I know
you've had spoken on it before about
just delving a little bit deeper into
the significance of where it took place
and who Lowry is and what what he's
become David well I mean he's an
ordinary Joe you know he's one of those
guys that you know he doesn't look like
or didn't look like he's going to be a
superstar you know just sort of a
journeyman pro although having said that
you know being a journeyman pro these
days you can still make a lot of money
it's really hard it's still a tough game
to make you know money you know but
there's a lot more of it around and you
know it the significance of the event at
royal Portrush you know the troubles
began the day after my 11th birthday and
I remember wondering you know at times
when there was a bomb going off near the
docks or something like where my father
worked you know if he was going to come
home and you know went on for the best
part of 30 years so you know to see it
was a big sporting event that the that
little country has ever seen you know
and to see it come there you know it's
kind of a leap of faith I think for the
RNA to to allow it to be there you know
so everyone was just incredibly grateful
and I think the players loved it the
Golf Course was incredible well it's an
incredible watch I mean I got you know I
got misty watching Shane Lowry come up
18 and I really didn't know much about
Shane to be very honest with you prior
to like say the last year and then
obviously reading about what what this
all meant to be in Northern Ireland it
was pretty amazing David and you know
that's part of the reason why I wanted
to have on today not just to give my boy
Mike del 2fo the requisite amount of
grief I know that's you Ted David listen
I really appreciate the quick callin
thank you so much and anytime you're in
Los Angeles welcome you're the Mad David
I'm rich you know time okay thank you
you got it that's it that's David Ferrie
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app